devenu hâtives et 78,1 me fait plaisir
de vous recevoir ici alors venez je vais
vous faire visiter la casse de babette
vous avez la casse de la boîte et toute
une histoire
ici c'était mon garage et j'avais vendu
tous mais resteront et j'avais dit à mon
mari
il va falloir absolument que je monte
quelque chose il donne n'était pas
d'accord et puis petit à petit vous avez
commencé des pharmas les femmes n'arrête
jamais et jusqu'au jour où il m'a dit
oui et j'ai transformé ce garage en
restaurant il ça donnait ça et puis on a
la chance aussi d'avoir un beau jardin
si vous voyez bien ce jardin il est un
peu conçues comme un jardin à
l'antillaise ya des paillotes en
biologie les petits clients amoureux il
yad'autres paillote on met un petit
groupe
et puis vous avez toute l'étendue du
jardin où les gens passent du bon temps
avec le bruit des oiseaux loin de paris
- vue brouillée et des gus évidemment
des spécialités antillaises
parce que je suis foncièrement
guadeloupéennes dont je ne fais que les
spécialistes en ciel venez vous faire
goûter un plat vous avez le temps alors
on va vous tranquilliser
alors je vous présente au mas qui est
mon second et qui est mon bras droit
quand je suis pas là c'est lui qui tient
la maison et ils tiennent bien la maison
ça fait des années qu'il est là avec moi
alors on va faire un petit mois cet
espace repas pessah safrané et
maintenant tu peux être jean gossement
allez on y va
accusés c'est une question d'amour en
cuisine parti soit nous les chefs en
cuisine pour faire plaisir à l'autre
collomb c'est pas comme ça on sait pas
ce que le client va dire mais lorsque la
passe est trop bien essuyer là on est
heureux on n'est pas nul parce que nous
avons accompli notre tâche
alors bon appétit m'a gardé